dass ich also vor die gelegenheit hierzu
nutzen weil mir das auch für die
zuschauer einfach weg sie wichtig wäre
aufklären und bin dankbar für die
gelegenheit die zuschauer direkt
ansprechen zu wollen aber wir haben
leider noch nicht hinter uns das ist
einfach so also wir werden jetzt wieder
steigende fallzahlen warten müssen
leider weil also bei der verwitterung
und bei mir innenraum aufenthalt werden
wieder mehr menschen sich gegenseitig
infizieren wir haben leider in der
altersgruppe der also 19 also bis 65
jährigen noch immer um die 30 prozent
die nicht geimpft sind wir sehen jetzt
dass bei der delta variante in dieser
altersgruppe viele auch schwer erkranken
ich sprach eben also noch mit dem leiter
der soko intensivstation der charité der
beobachtet das gleiche was wir in köln
auch sehen dass es eben die schweren
verläufe sind die dann lange liegen das
heißt ich will dass die menschen sparen
und wir haben daher nicht die
voraussetzung das ist der springende
punkt wir haben es nicht geschafft die
voraussetzungen zu erbauen für einen
frieden wir haben es nicht geschafft sie
könnten wenn es weniger ungeimpfte geben
könnten wir jetzt in frieden machen das
wäre möglich aber es hat werden sind es
uns einfach nicht gelungen ich kann
nicht also mit etwa 15 prozent bei den
über 65 jährigen die nicht geimpft sind
und bei 30 prozent also bei den unter
65-jährigen die umgehend sind kann ich
kein frieden die machen das geht einfach
nicht es wird dann sehr viel
schwerverkehr woher weiß ich dass ihre
prognose stimmt und dass das was sie uns
jetzt gerade sagen mit den steinen files
seien die panini ist noch nicht zu ende
das ist wirklich wahr es sie haben auch
falsche prognosen in den letzten jahren
getroffen eine aber eine fahne ich aber
wirklich schlimm und ich war hatte hallo
da wirklich eine frage ich habe mir eben
bei ihnen entschuldigt und ich habe mich
gefragt ob sie sich für diese aussage
eigentlich auch mal entschuldigen
wollten oder das gefühl hatten wie ich
das heute abend hatte dass man da
wirklich vielleicht mal es gab im
österreichischen virologen er hat sich
entschuldigt daten brief geschrieben es
tut mir leid diese falsche prognose und
das ist die von ihnen sieben prozent der
kinder das ist unstrittig die sie
infizieren entwickeln lankowitz symptome
da weiß man ja heute dass es falsch ist
also alles was ich recherchiert habe und
was andere biologen sagen auf was die
zahlen hergeben ist die aussage noch
fall spanien oder nein ist es nicht
fertig also ist es gibt nach wie vor
also daten
also diese aussage also belegen es kommt
aber darauf an wie man das also
betrachtet also wenn man die kinder mit
berücksichtigt die sich infizieren aber
nie symptome haben dann sind die sieben
prozent zu hoch aber die 7 prozent
bezogen sich auf die kinder die symptome
aber er wollte mir kaum kinder symptome
das war so wie sie es gesagt haben haben
wir natürlich eine totale panik mache
bei den eltern die meisten kinder haben
sind ja symptomatisch das heißt so anna
wasser ausgetreten da muss man es schon
wenn ich keine symptome habe kann ich
auch keine langzeit symptom haben also
ich habe vielleicht hätte man hätte man
da ein bisschen klarer ist
also wenn ich davon ausgehe dass also
kinder langzeit symptom haben dann kann
das natürlich nicht die kinder betreffen
die gar keine symptome haben haben keine
symptome der kinder das kommt darauf an
also wie alt die kinder sind das also
also das kommt sehr stark auf die
altersgruppe an aber ich würde mal
schätzen dass jetzt ein schätzwert habe
ich kann also präzise studiert war das
sehr stark altersabhängig würde man
vielleicht vermuten dass also 20 prozent
der kinder irgendwelche symptome haben
die sich infizieren und der grundgedanke
ist 80 prozent haben keiner der kinder
haben keine symptome
wäre jetzt quasi also das hängt sehr vom
alter wie älter die kinder sind desto
höher ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
die kinder symptome entwickeln aber
diese zahl 80 prozent haben keine das
freut ihn ja das ist ja gegen die panik
89 prozent der kinder haben keine saison
aber ich gehe sie aber nicht richtiger
werden so also sagen wir wenn die
beschreibung der fakten sofort als
panikmache
war das ist also der wissenschaftler
also geht davon aus wenn ich sage 7
prozent der kinder entwickeln longo
fehlt dann denke ich natürlich dass
jeder mit denkt dass das natürlich nur
die kinder betreffen kann die überhaupt
symptome sonst könnten die kinder die
sind thoma haben haben die symptome dann
länger dass die kinder die keine
symptome haben auch keine langfristigen
symptome aber dabei herrlich bei dem was
sie auch gerade am anfang gesagt haben
dass sie jetzt wieder mit
intensivmedizinern gesprochen haben das
soll uns vorbereiten wollen hier wieder
auf einen ganz schlimmen herbst da hab
ich ein ganz schreckliches déjà vu und
denke ist der lauterbach der ist er
wieder unterwegs jetzt mit den experten
heute haben sie dann posten getroffen
und ich habe da massiven angst vor dem
neuen lockdown wenn ich höre dass die
schulbücher von von zahlen sprechen in
den intensiv die hochgehen und das wird
das war doch am ende auch panikmache
wenn man das mal zusammen fast wie oft
davor gewarnt wurde das angeblich die
intensiv kapazitäten überschritten sind
so oft wie das gewarnt wurde da frage
ich mich was also
um klarzustellen also es wird kein
lockerungen gegeben der wird auch nicht
nötig sein weil die welle die jetzt
kommt diese vierte welle wird nicht die
dimensionen haben der wellen die wir
gehabt haben das ist ganz klar weil eben
doch ein viel größerer anteil der
bevölkerung geimpft ist von daher kann
man in diesen modellierungen klar
darstellen es gibt noch eine weile aber
diese wo diese welle wird nicht so
bitter sein wie die wellen die wir
hatten und auch nicht so hart rein
schlagen wie die welle die man in den
vereinigten staaten sieht weil dort die
in quote noch niedriger aber es ist
einfach so man muss also
die dinge beim namen nennen also wir
haben jetzt um die 1500 intensivbetten
die wieder gefüllt sind die leute die
jetzt liegen liegen länger die anderen
fälle müssen auch versorgt werden dann
ist man ruckzuck schon wieder am rande
der jetzt gab es heute einen vorschlag
der mich schockiert hat im spiegel
markus schreiber ich verbinde die
verhaltensforscher der hat gesagt
ungeimpfte da sollte man dann
übertrieben die ta sprechen und sagen
mehr oder weniger wäre ungeimpft ist er
bekommt dann auch kein bett also in der
phase sind wir schon wir mit unheimlich
sind wir nicht also an der phase sind
wir dazu sagen komplett unnötig
vorschlag da brauchen wir nicht eine
sekunde darüber dass ich habe es schon
ich habe es sogar für falsch gehalten
dass wir gesagt haben die ungeimpften
kontaktpersonen die in kanada hatte ja
damals dabei bleiben dass wir überhaupt
dass es soweit gekommen ist dass wir
über sowas sprechen dass sein markus
schreiber dort das erzählt er sei es
immens also wer's markus habe in der
regierung wird das nicht diskutiert
das wird unter also wissenschaftlern die
die regierung unmittelbar beraten nicht
diskutiert das ist kein vorschlag den
ich ja so der klub derjenigen die sachen
das regierungsgeschäft beraten
diesbezüglich also wer kommt nicht auf
die idee also so dass wird das wird im
engeren zirkel der telefonieren sie noch
mit der kanzlerin über grund würde ich
auf keinen fall so viel
theorie immer in die öffentlichkeit
kommen bei krones und interessantes
thema ist und wir uns bewegt immer noch
sehr stark das heißt jeder der eine
interessante meinung dazu hat oder was
komisches sagt der ist damit natürlich
auch in der öffentlichkeit und hat auch
einstand ich finde auch wir sollten mal
eines anerkannt karl lauterbach ist auch
ein bisschen in diese richtung gekommen
dadurch auch missinterpretation als
derjenige der immer coole theorien von
sich gibt beschimpft worden ist als
spacken von herrn kubicki zu unrecht
auch denn es war auch von
einem jahr wir wollen das thema
relativieren genau trotzdem nicht so
feiern hat sich entschuldigt sich
entschuldigen ist auch gut damit aber
wir sollten auch sagen es war karl
lauterbach auch der schon im februar
2020 1 es hier noch den ersten corona
fall gab in deutschland darauf
hingewiesen hat dass das ein weitaus
schwereren verlauf geben könnte als bei
der grippe mit todesfolge und
dergleichen und eigentlich immer da der
mann in der war von anfang an und auch
in vielen was er gesagt hat recht
behalten hat also insofern muss man ihr
auch dankbar sein für diese rolle die
ihr eingenommen hat immer zu mahnen
darum muss sie das jetzt sorgen machen
oder das vor lauter er hat uns ja gerade
eben gesagt dass er nicht mit einem
weiteren lockdown rechnet aber
vielleicht ist es realistisch zu sagen
wenn wir alle sagen mensch wie ich will
das vorbei ist diese maske abnehmen will
wollen wir ja alle zu sagen ist bleibt
vorsichtig na ja auch nur zu seinen
kollegen als sowohl die liebe bleibt
vorsichtig das eine ich finde wie die
politik muss einfach sicherstellen wir
wollen ja dass mehr menschen geimpft
werden wie sollen die abgeholt werden es
ist immer nur dann kommen irgendwelche
kruden theorien irgendwie
oder man darf nicht mehr in restaurants
gehen wenn man nicht geimpft ist man
darf dies nicht mehr man das nicht mehr
machen jetzt stehen wir vor der frage
was ist denn wenn kinder ab fünf geimpft
werden können werden kinder nachher auch
nicht mehr irgendwo teilnehmen können
weil sie nicht geimpft sind und das ist
einfach so der punkt wo ich denke wie
will man die leute abholen immer nur mit
druck und ihr müsst und ansonsten kommt
ihr nicht mehr da rein und ansonsten
geht dies und das nicht mehr man muss
doch mal überlegen wie kann man die
ängste der leute vielleicht auch in
irgendeiner form bedienen weil ich kenne
zum beispiel einige menschen in meinem
umfeld die sich nicht haben impfen
lassen das sind weder querdenker sondern
noch sind dass irgendwelche kronach
sagen die wir haben einfach angst sie
sind unsicher die sagen ich weiß nicht
was ist dann in 20 jahren mit mir ich
bin noch jung ich trau mich nicht ich
habe angst um mein leben und ehrlich
gesagt unsere tochter wird nächstes jahr
5 da denke ich auch will ich jetzt
wirklich mein fünfjähriges kind impfen
lassen das macht auch mir angst und da
finde ich werden wir viel zu wenig
abgeholt ich bin auch geimpft und finde
auch dass es wichtig ist aber ich kann
auch die angst der menschen verstehen
und da finde ich versagt die politik an
vielen stellen auch weil es eben
vorausgesetzt wird du musst es jetzt
machen du musst das verstehen aber die
ängste der menschen werden überhaupt
nicht in irgendeiner form angesprochen
ich finde das interessant punkte also
lassen wir die kinder mal außen vor hat
das ist dass kinder hat würde ich aber
auch gerne mal drauf ich wollte mir dazu
zwei sätzen sagen also dass kinder also
bestimmte sachen nicht machen dürfen
weil sie nicht geimpft wären das geht
gar nicht das ist gabmann können ja auch
nicht ausschließen dass das passiert ich
weiß sehr wohl ausschließen das halte
ich für ein abwägen vorschlag und ich
kenne niemanden also
der in der wissenschaft das vorschlagen
das ist auch irgendwo das ist auch also
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt gibt es den
impfstoff war so
also ich will es mal einfach ausdrucken
das ist etwas was wir nicht machen sich
sicher sein dass wir kinder ausschließen
das werden wir nicht also das konnte
sich auch niemand dass ich ohne geimpfte
ausschließen nimmt das team nicht ins
kino oder ins ressort ja aber das ist
doch eine ganz andere geschichte also
bei kindern also haben wir solche dinge
nicht gemacht also wenn jetzt ein
erwachsener und sich nicht impfen lassen
will und sagt ich hab ich fühle mich
unwohl damit vielleicht so ist dem vom
später gefährlich vielleicht erzählt
euch da hat mir nicht die volle wahrheit
oder was sind das denn für wissenschaft
uns waren sie auch medizinisch begründet
sein gerne auf seinem rad aber bleiben
wir mal bei dem üblichen und die dort
habe ich ja im wahlkampf überall gesehen
ich sagen das ist mir zu riskant wer
weiß was 22 jahren ist ich traue der
wissenschaftlich das ist alles also
pharmaindustrie uns weiter wenn jemand
der bereit ist ins risiko zu gehen und
akzeptiert die also gängiger
wissenschaft nicht wunderbar es war für
uns schade war das sind die leute die
dazu beitragen dass wir die maske so
lange tragen müssen aber das akzeptieren
wir zum schluss irgendwann werden diese
leute alle das ist ganz klar infiziert
gewesen sein aber diese leute können
jetzt nicht verlangen dass sie behandelt
werden wie geimpfte zu nachdem dahin
wirklich ein klassengesellschaft geimpft
und umgebung seien freunde wenn zum
beispiel eine bei mir ich muss jetzt
auch wieder sagt ich bin geimpft genau
so wie du es übrigens auch gesagt dass
warum sagen der wein oder ich kann doch
eher mit wir hier eher sympathisch
wirken wie er die geimpften sind ich
möchte das nicht ich möchte nicht in
einem land leben wo zwischen geimpften
unterschieden was ist wenn ich denn da
noch nicht das muss nicht doch also ich
möchte ich nicht missen die da sind
haben wir die einfach unterschiedliche
risiken tragen ich kann noch nicht im
geringsten erlauben dass er sich und
andere gefährden etwas wie eine klammer
bei der restaurant herr lauterbach eine
frage letztes jahr im sommer bei der
restaurantbesuch möglich ohne dass man
ausweis fort minor konnte ja noch nicht
impfen ich weiß dass also sie sagen
aktuell mit blick auf die zahlen ist es
nicht anders möglich als die menschen
die ausweise vorzeigen zu lassen nein
wir wollen sie wollen auch druck auf die
umgehende das ist auch so dass das ist
nicht so dass wird immer gesagt
impfpflicht durchstehen
bevor ich also
also vielleicht
so dass ich nie ich habe
in meinem alter muss ich sie fragen
nacheinander bekommen haben diese also
zunächst einmal ist nicht die pflicht
durch den top wir sondern wenn ich die
ungeimpften jetzt auch so ins restaurant
hineinlasse das was kelter daher die
fenster und türen sind zu dann würden
sich also die ungenutzten untereinander
infizieren und im übrigen sogar dem wir
gehen essen wurden infiziert weil ich
natürlich durch ko infektionen haben
somit also habe ich an der situation die
vergleichbar ist mit einem schwimmbad
besuch im schwimmbad gibt es auch eine
zweiklassengesellschaft es gibt
diejenigen nicht schwimmen kann und die
nichtschwimmer- und die nichtschwimmer
die dürfen nicht ins tiefe und die
ungeimpften die sind die duh november
treten ja aber natürlich das schwimmbad
aber die dürfen nicht also in das also
in das schwimmerbecken
dieser freiwillig rein springen und das
kann ich nicht machen ich kann auch also
ich da ich würde es also ich es ist
nicht erlaubt dass also das ist einfach
nicht richtig und nicht erlaubt neben
hat will das von uns dass die nicht
schwimmer also ins schwimmerbecken
springen das ist einfach nicht erlaubt
ich kann auch die nicht schwimmer nicht
also ihrem risiko weil es so nach dem
motto auch für nichtschwimmer erlaubt
vier meter tief das wird nicht gehen und
das ist als vergleich der nicht ganz
abwegig ist hängt ein bisschen aber ist
nicht ganz abwegig weil die wenn die
ungeimpften hier sind die engen räume
rangehen und also schenken sich
gegenseitig an dann landen viele von
ihnen genau dort wo auch der also nicht
schön mal landet auf der intensiven test
muss ja auch mal das ist für mich so
eine basta-politik entweder macht das
und wenn es nicht macht friss oder stirb
sondern dem motto ich möchte gern wissen
wie wollen sie die leute ab und wir
wollen doch dass mehr leute dort mache
ich doch den also jetzt so eine aussage
finde ich nicht dass sie abholt würde
ich doch die geimpften können das also
schwimmerbecken und die uns nicht wenn
man
gewisse sensibilität weil die leute
haben die haben für sich persönliche
gründe warum sie es nicht machen wollen
und ich möchte für niemanden hier ist ja
gerade
wir wollen doch dahin dass sich mehr
menschen impfen lassen und dann muss ich
doch einfach mal gucken wo sind deren
schmerzen was kann ich tun damit sie
sich besser fühlen damit sie vielleicht
doch sagen dass sie das mache ich wenn
ich doch den ganzen tag ich muss lea ich
will die impfung laut den jahrestag
erkläre ich das ist bei impfungen ist es
musste erst einmal dazwischen weil wir
nämlich den viele themen haben und
tatsächlich ist das wahnsinnig spannend
aber zum abschluss weil sie so viel über
regierung und was sie jetzt machen und
tun in diesen tagen und sich beraten
kann das sein dass bald der
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach
entscheidet wie wir corona und konform
verhalten müssen wenn die spd in die
regierung kommt und das
gesundheitsministerium bekommt darüber
hat sich noch gar keine gelegenheit nach
das kommt jetzt ganz neu
überraschen
aber wenn
sie denn bereit aber auch wenn jetzt die
andrucke und sagt mensch halt du musst
das machen ja darauf selbst darüber
sollte man nicht öffentlich spekulieren
aber wir werden schon bereit oder sagen
wir so dass das mich gesund hat
interessiert also auch also politisch
interessiert das haben wir gemerkt das
ist ja klar und also von daher von einer
dramatischen überforderung juni ausgehen
aber es ist auf jeden fall nichts
worüber ich wirklich ernsthaft jetzt
viel nachgedacht habe es gibt wohl
allerdings andere dinge andere dinge die
jetzt basierend zu entscheiden
[Musik]